Jason first of all congratulations uh
backpack victories for you an important
one with the white pieces once again
Arthur decided to play the same line and
got a losing position out of the opening
to come B2 did you know at this point
that you're winning
because these eyes have arrived in your
preparation summer
yeah it's funny actually I think I
looked at this position uh before the
game and I knew Bishop's hd7 was like a
possibility but during the game somehow
I wasn't so sure like it's obviously
easy with the engine and everything of
course
but you probably had this also as you
mentioned in your preparation right well
not exactly I mean I didn't expect him
to go for this to be honest so
yeah it was really unclear because I've
after Knight F2 came out too I mean this
position looks great but I felt like we
could like D6 Bishop B7 Queen D7 maybe
long castle and it wasn't so clear to me
yeah fair enough because I also thought
like why complicate Demars because if
black one Bishop C3 instead of Knight
takes B2
I mean we transposed to the game anyways
of nice c39 and was this your
preparation uh this was this was okay
yeah okay so very nice I felt like I had
a big Advantage here anyways but it was
a lot more clear to me during the game
so I decided to just go for this and
then things got a bit crazy towards this
part and then I don't think I should
have played H5 H5 was probably too early
that's right that's right H5 was a
little bit premature but it helps him
activate his night
this one yeah here I really thought he
should go Knight G6 night shape kind of
shocked me no my G6 makes a lot of sense
as well
um I'm not sure what he was scared of
there was some like nice C6 Queen F6 E5
I saw this during the game I had no idea
what was going on here that's the thing
you don't know the assessment during the
game right it's just it's it's very very
difficult completely different ball game
he decided to go with the Knight G8
maybe a bit more
safe right right but then you got this
move in I really like this one E5 nice
break in the center because otherwise
he's got Castle King side if I go like
F4
so I felt I needed to play E5
immediately and then E5 is going to be
much more difficult to make right
nice
and how did you assess your chances at
this point
yeah it was
if I was winning but it was unclear I
saw Queen at Faye here I
yeah I kind of missed this from afar and
I wasn't really sure how to evaluate I
thought I should still be much better
but maybe it's not so simple takes B6
Queen takes H6
now you have to take but you have to
contend with the a pawn yeah this is not
what I want it's getting scary
but maybe you still have a way King the
two Rook H1 somehow get back in time
Knight C3 as well to stop it he didn't
see it he played Bishop takes F5 and
after this
you are broke through very nice and
finished it off in style
you know Jason six rounds in the books
how would you assess your performance so
far
well I mean I think I'm pretty happy so
far I mean the rest day really helped me
um transition to a new tournament
I just hope to get as many points as I
can at this point you know having
a not so good start but now coming in
with two and a half out of three I'm
feeling pretty confident for the next
three games Jason congratulations guys
any questions uh not for me but uh
foreign
was still in the center but you are not
worried at all I mean your queen was on
H6 just just I mean great kind of
positional pieces around but what is
your attitude towards sacrificing pawns
are the ones who give them for free
pretty frequently or are you more of
those porn Grabbers who just tries to
keep them and this was just like an
exception to your play
yeah normally I'm pretty materialistic
actually
but yes I feel like yeah yeah I like to
grab the pawns as well
um
but in this case I felt like sacking and
pawns didn't really matter because I'm
just opening up all the lines and he has
like very poor development
and also his Pawn structure was just
terrible like they were all doubled and
isolated and everything so I wasn't too
worried about being down three pawns and
like in the game I was going to win back
at least one of them pretty soon
so no second thoughts about giving up
pawns you were three pawns down but you
were like everything is under control
yeah yeah I felt like my initiative
fully compensated for the material
deficit
absolutely by the way we've got a number
of endings that uh